bonjour à tous le jour d'hui une vidéo
que j'aurais dû faire depuis un bon
petit moment et je vous prie de
m'excuser d'avoir pris du retard
il ya quelques temps de sayanim quelques
mois de ça j'ai organisé un concours
pour gagner le jeu one to switch un jeu
qui est effectivement qui parle pour la
console la nintendo sweet qui est sorti
il ya quelques mois je vais organiser un
concours pour gagner ce fameux jeu jeu
que j'ai acheté avec mes propres données
personnelles pour vous faire vous un
cadeau le concours était assez simple il
suffisait effectivement 22 commentent et
partagent et enfin briller un petit peu
la mécanique classique qu'on a sur les
jeux youtube
je vais aujourd'hui dévoilé le nom du ou
de la gagnante de la personne qui va
remporter son jeu aux 28 et qui va le
recevoir
déjà je voulais remercier effectivement
tous les participants vous avez été
nombreux à participer au concours donc
un grand merci à vous tous je vous prie
vraiment de m'excuser une fois de plus
pour le retard que j'ai pris pour
effectivement annoncé le ou la gagnante
du concours
c'était un petit peu long mais des fois
le plaisir se fait dans la tente
on va regarder tout de suite qui a gagné
pour définir la personne qui allait
gagner c'était pas très compliqué j'ai
regardé effectivement les commentaires
j'en ai sélectionné quelques-uns qui
m'ont le plus plu et puis le plus touché
c'était compliqué de départager le
gagnant donc j'ai choisi de faire un
tirage au sort et ce tirage au sort a
désigné la personne suivante il s'agit
de ananda games
je vous lis son message bonjour monsieur
gros je pense que ça devrait être moi
car le jeu one to switch pour moi est
très cher et que moi et mes parents on
pense que ce serait un très bon jeu et
aussi j'ai déjà tenté par un concours et
je n'ai jamais gagné donc gagner au
moins un concours serait top
j'aimerais que quand tu lises mon
message tu penses vraiment un la joie
que ça me ferais si je gagnais et que tu
comprenne vraiment pourquoi j'écris un
message aussi long et travail est fait
exprès pour concours je te remercierai
énormément si tu me choisit sinon
courage pour tes vidéos je t'adore merci
beaucoup pour ton message qui m'a touché
je t'offre avec un grand plaisir want to
switch j'espère que entre-temps battu
l'a pas acheté un certain serait quand
même dommage
si c'est le cas dis-le moi que je
offre à quelqu'un d'autre j'ai pas de
souci si tu ne l'as pas et que tu le
veux toujours je t'ai demandé de
m'envoyer un message privé sur youtube
ou via l'adresse e-mail qui indiquait
dans ma description à propos tu
m'envoies des coordonnées nom prénom
adresse postale numéro de téléphone et
moi je t'ai expédie sa extrêmement
rapidement
merci à tous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
je suis aujourd'hui sur un format un
petit peu court un trait particulier
pour effectivement l' annonce du gagnant
ou de la gagnante enfin de la personne
qui a gagné le giro vannetais switch
merci à tous d'avoir participé
je vous dis à très bientôt et puis vous
organiserez très probablement un autre
concours très prochainement donc restez
connectés châu
[Musique]